speaking of things falling apart you
guys went to california
i have this story here from usa today
they say
california is a failed state how do we
know
they're moving to arizona in droves the
story is from
august 31st but they say a few things i
want to highlight before we talk about
what you guys is because you guys went
actually talked to business owners and
people have been impacted by the failed
policies of california they say
california's energy policies have failed
they say so have those policies to stop
homelessness
harsh pandemic response didn't help move
here
leave those policies at home what
they're talking about now as people in
california leave
they're bringing the politics with them
that destroyed the state
so this is a story i covered quite a bit
ago
there there was uh you know the failure
of california there was also
the return of bubonic plague typhoid
outbreaks
disease homelessness so you guys put
together you did a documentary is that
what you did
yeah so what happened tim is we actually
kind of stumbled on this project on
accident um so i i went back home to
to california to my my hometown and in
palmdale so i went back around
thanksgiving
and you know being here in um you know
covering politics in dc you do
even though i always hated myself where
is like you do get stuck in kind of like
a dc bubble you know you forget
how bad the pandemic is for the rest of
americans so as soon as i landed back
back home in california for thanksgiving
break i visit my hometown
and it's it's decimated it's just you
know
unemployment is high most of my friends
their their parents own these
restaurants now they're going out of
business
uh you know it's just it's just horrible
so i i right there was like
do you know the unemployment rate right
now in california i don't know the
unemployment rate but as of right now
um we do have 17 percent of restaurants
across the u.s so about 110
establishments are closed permanently
and yeah and um in november the
restaurant industry lost over 2 million
jobs
wow so being in in california i started
talking to the restaurant owners
about the outdoor dining ban just how
they're doing so as soon as i started
interviewing
um these restaurant owners it was
powerful stuff like they would be crying
in my face saying hey jorge
on thanksgiving week we get the news of
the outdoor dining ban
we have to now lay off the majority of
our staff and it's like and what they
made me realize too is like we're not
just laying off
workers these are families that you know
these people have to put food on the
table
and also kind of being in this project i
got to learn that
a lot of these couples both of the
couples would be in the restaurant
industry so now you have two servers
now let go no help from the government
and then at the same time
since they're in the working class their
kids are at home all day on zoom
their kids depression is up so it's just
this horrible thing so
sonic came down and we were able to
really focus in on these american
stories because like a lot of these
restaurants feel like they've been left
behind
not only that another aspect is they
spent thousands of thousands of dollars
on outdoor dining and just accommodating
to
to california's crazy rules i mean l.a
county was the only county
to do an outdoor dining event so just in
l.a county that's affecting 30
000 restaurants these people were told
we're shutting down indoor dining
so they spend tons of money to set up
outdoor dining exactly and then as soon
as they do they go ah
that's bantu and not only that tim the
crazy thing is is
evil the brewery the breweries in l.a
county were already
um they're they couldn't serve outdoors
unless they had a
a kitchen so i was able to interview one
brewer who spent a hundred grand
on the kitchen just to serve outdoors
only for for two weeks later
the county said nope done shut it down
so you have this
massive brewery stuck on take out beers
it's impossible and it's just
heartbreaking to hear the owners say
we love this business and we don't want
to let people go but at this point
what what can we do we're putting this
tough corner so the beautiful thing was
is that
you know me and signing really got to
document these stories tell these
people's stories and when we put a
documentary together
it's it we released it actually today so
it's on daily caller um check it out we
worked really hard on it and then it
really meant a lot to the to the richer
to the restaurant because for them they
feel like they don't have a voice but
this is the kind of thing you got to
send to your friends who don't believe
you
that's yes the people who think
everything's fine or that that we're not
facing serious trouble
let them see let them see let them hear
in the words of the people who actually
had their lives yes
sorry i know you you got to work with me
when you talk to these people one thing
you realize like the people in dc are
like people in new york or people who
are on media
they have given people this easily
digestible pill which is like a single
variable way of thinking like during
this pandemic the only thing we have to
consider is life saved versus life's not
saved like the only thing you need to
worry about saving lives they don't
consider the fact these
that these people who run these bars who
run these restaurants they have lives
too
like though if you like close them and
then you say like oh yes we are saving
lives like that's not a solution
that's just a lazy way of thinking like
there are other variables to consider
here
like like the waiter he has a job he
probably has a family he has a child
like what about him
that's one factor about it and the
second factor is
like the hypocrisy like if you like
drive like 10 minutes away from these
restaurants you
walk into target where people are
crowded in like gajillion numbers
especially during
holiday seasons and that's like
literally in front of these people like
you can like look out of their
restaurants which are closed and you see
these
like like target packed and they realize
that these
like lockdown measures do not make any
sense whatsoever and the fact that it's
so blatant
is like insulting to them you know i
think it might be a red pill for a lot
of these small businesses
exactly yeah but i think most people are
going to keep voting d they're going to
walk in and go
democrat and they're going to walk out
and walk away it's going to keep
happening it's not going to stop
yeah look we don't know what's gonna
happen either that or like people who
have the resources to leave
will leave like but unfortunately these
people do not have the resources to
leave they have pulled their lives
savings into you know creating something
out of nothing
and hiring people and like once you have
that mentality which is like
okay my job is to be responsible to like
put food on other people's table like my
waiters my
chefs you have you're living like a
different life you're not living a life
off like a staff ride in a new york
times
who lives in a pot and whose only job is
to ride like you're responsible for
other people you're in
like you're an entrepreneur and like
people do not empathize with these
people easily and the media has done
like a horrible job of translating that
well because they live in europe the
journalists are like that randall
yeah they they're not gonna come out and
be like oh you poor restaurant owner no
we already saw one story
where there was a business they set up
they had a walkway and they put a tent
over it and put tables there so that
people could
use their public walkways at outdoor
dining and the journalists snitched on
them
and said we need to inform new york
they're doing this yeah and then the
the interesting thing too tim is in
california you know i've
grown up there my whole life but when i
was growing up in the early 90s
um you know california was a state where
everyone in around the country was
moving to the golden state you know you
wanted to be in california i remember
when i was growing up you know my dad is
an immigrant from el salvador he just
has a sixth grade education
my dad was able to have the family of
five on one income he was a trucker
and you know we would go on vacation we
owned our cars that life is gone in cali
in california it's becoming almost like
a latin america economy where
the the lowest class doesn't pay for
anything because everything's subsidized
um the middle and the working class pay
for absolutely everything and they're
living on scrum
they're other ones have to get by and
the rich it's all good for the actors
and everyone else so i
i in the documentary too i say you know
this is the golden state it's now
only golding for the elites and everyone
else is left behind one of the more
powerful interviews
that i got to him is i interviewed a
owner of a pizza restaurant
and when we spoke about the gavin newsom
situation she was just crying in my face
saying it's an absolutely slap in the
face
for him to be able to eat in the french
laundry indoors
while i have to lay off my employees who
are literally making like
13 bucks an hour you know some of these
folks are surviving on like 120 bucks a
week to
having kids i mean depression is going
up it's honestly some of the saddest
saddest things that we're seeing and
we're just trying to focus on these
stories because it just feels like
the average american story is not
getting told and
you know i think it was a blessing for
me to get out of that dc bubble and to
see it and say you know what
this is what i need to really be focused
on is telling these stories and the next
project we'll be working on and we don't
want to get too much input
we're going to be interviewing parents
and they're going to be talking to me
about you know their kids going through
this depression uh indoors
i um you know i put out a tweet saying
hey parents reach out to me and
tim i got over 100 messages and this is
kind of the sentiment of these messages
saying
hey i had an eight-year-old a 10 year
old 12 year old they were all a's
athletic now into the pandemic all f's
social anxiety doesn't want to talk to
me
i'm speaking to a dad right now where
his son grabbed his gun because he fell
into depression during his kobe lockdown
12 years old
he shot himself in the mouth trying to
kill himself but the way he shot it
thank god
he's in stable condition we're going to
be interviewing him to tell the story
but
this stuff is tim is just not getting
told in the news and not only that
and um when i was speaking to his
parents now that made me realize they're
telling me like hey jorge i'm making
less money because of the pandemic my
kids are stuck at home depression's up
i'm also spending more on groceries
double because since the kids are home
they're eating more so it's just all
these little things that you you
we would never consider and sometimes
you know look i know what happened in
the capital
obviously that's big news and we need we
need to talk about it but at the end of
the
day
let's not forget that you know average
americans can't put food on the table
and it's not only california it's across
the state you know we could only focus
there but
let's not forget about the average
americans they're getting left behind
during this i was reading uh
there's something a doctor gave an
interview or something where he talked
about he's never seen such deterioration
not just from older folks but from even
kids kids yeah kids becoming out of
shape overweight their blood pressure's
bad
they're like just obese diabetic because
they're not exercising they're sitting
in all day they're not getting vitamin d
and they're getting depressed social
anxiety for these kids yeah they're
becoming like you know
uh just a home body lying around with
bed sores
crumbs on their chest and then they're
supposed to interact through
you know computers man get out of these
cities the best thing you can do i guess
but some people can't do it you're
trapped exactly like like a lot of
people like people like oh leave
california just move to texas like move
to nashville it's like
a lot of people do not have like you
know means to do that and california
let's not forget it's like a beautiful
state
it's like a huge beautiful state where
like a lot of people live and
a huge sloth of population like feel
like they're left behind
just because of the governor just
because of the mirror and it's just like
a
horroring thing to see and like when you
meet these people the thing you realize
is that
like they are so like the fact that
like tucker talks about a lot of the
fact that classified like it is so
obvious to them that people when people
think about california they think about
oh the place where actors live oh well
like celebrities live
but the fact that they're like actual
waiters or actual restaurant owners who
not have jobs
like that is classified you know i was
thinking something i was like
when i saw gavin newsom doing that fancy
dinner
french longria what was it what was it
called french laundry french laundry
yeah that's the name of the restaurant
it's one of the most fanciest
restaurants in the world i mean the bill
was
400 grand ish 400 grand
what what the bill how much was the bill
for that that's what that's what the
pizza owner told me like the bills
should be like closer to 400 grand like
12 people
12 people ate there in in vegas i
remember shane smith from vice
spent 300 thousand dollars i think on
dinner
but yeah yeah so when i when i saw that
i have never been closer to raising my
fist and yelling workers of the world
unite
seriously yeah but but that's like
socialism but here's what i'm thinking
like
is there is there a thing where we can
like unite the workers but not as
communists
and just be like yo these politicians
that's the new right dude that's the new
right that's the populist new riot well
like people realize that we
us being workers have been left behind
by the government and the only like the
way to unite is like not exactly like
following bernie's rule but like what
tucker says
it's like you as a worker have a right
like the fact that
the whole concept of like someone having
a job like the same job at retiring at
60 years old with this rolex
is like outdated should be worrisome
so yeah let me say probably one of the
most bannable things
uh so so let's let's recognize people on
the right should not be voting for
republicans
let's see we see what they do no they
hate their own voters right yeah but
let's also recognize
the left should not be voting for
democrats yep so everybody made a
mistake here
how about we all agree the workers
should unite but not to
change the like not not to make
socialism
just to get rid of corrupt crooked
politicians
and i mean this peacefully i mean we
need to have people come together
a populist movement saying we might not
agree on the economic policy but we can
all agree the elites
don't have our back and are selling us
out yeah and stripping away our access
and our rights
and our liberties and if the workers do
unite it doesn't have to be for
communism
it can just be for the american rights
and the right to
make a living like yeah like if i'm
being honest i was like far from being
like a
like populist guy like i was like clo i
would be i would say like i was close to
being like a new conservative like
before this year began but like when
paul ryan conservative
when this year started rolling down i
realized that like holy
this class divide is like so obvious and
like
these like the washington like does not
give a single crap about any of these
people
at all like if they're like like the the
stimulus thing was like
the perfect example for that like i
talked to this waitress who was like 28
years old
single mother has like a four-year-old
son and she was like the last templates
i got was like when everyone else got
there like 1600
dollars like back in like april may i
don't remember and like that was the
last one and like and ever since that
i've been earning 200
a week and like like i have a son who's
like two years old like what about him
you know i think people need to start
realizing you can't count on government
you can count on them to to put the
roadblocks up but not to give you the
food after they they screw you over and
so
i know a lot of people don't want to
hear it and it's maybe easier for me to
say
but we're going back to you know we're
going back in time in terms of our in
terms of look
let me stop there we were in a golden
age for a long time you go to the store
you get cheeseburgers you get pizzas
boom just like that for for dirt you go
home you put in the freezer you put in
the freezer you put in the oven you got
food
that's that's easy living you know
people used to have to work from sundown
just to have enough food to survive
and it was work non-stop and we're
heading back in that direction
for whatever reason you want to say i
think people need to become self-reliant
independent
start realizing the government's not
going to get your back and even if we do
change these politicians it's not going
to change
anything no power power tends to corrupt
an absolute power tends to corrupt
absolutely i mean wages has been going
down in this country for the past 30
years and they keep going down
life expectancy in america is i think
it's like where like it's just dropping
dropping
dropping because now americans have to
work more jobs um we also have the
opioid crisis
it's i mean and then the pandemic
obviously doesn't doesn't help
economy yeah yep back to your point like
the thing is like
yes like metatron metocracy is like
still a thing
and like people should like believe in
it but at the same time people should
always question like these
congregation of powers and anytime
there's like this like unwarranted
like mammoth of power to any corporation
to any government people should like
question that or at least like is this
right that this one company has like
access to
everything that we do like websites
groceries
like flight tickets like everything like
you if you fall out of line
and this company doesn't like it like
that's it that like that's it for you're
banished from like normal society
that's why i think we might be heading
towards peaceful divorce as many people
have called it
because like i said people who can't get
jobs anymore because
you know blue states won't hire them
they can get jobs in west virginia and
wyoming and nebraska or whatever
but i guess we'll see how it plays out
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you